the entire world mourning the loss of an
irreplaceable icon as our greatest ally
embarks on a new era under a new king
queen elizabeth ii resting in eternal
peace after passing away at the age of
96.
tributes have been pouring in from
dignitaries and fans across the globe as
thousands of brits descended upon
buckingham palace to pay their respects
her life was nothing short of incredible
she reigned through 15 prime ministers
the first being winston churchill and
through 14 different u.s presidencies
spanning nearly 30 percent of u.s
history
king charles iii starting his first full
day on the throne by greening mourners
at buckingham palace and consoling his
nation with this extraordinary and
moving speech
my beloved mother
was an inspiration an example to me
and to all my family
and we owe her the most heartfelt debt
any family could owe to their mother
queen elizabeth was a life well lived
a promise with destiny kept
and she is mourned most deeply in her
passing i shall endeavor to serve you
with loyalty
respect
and love
as i have throughout my life
william
now assumes the scottish titles which
have meant so much to me
i want also to express
my love for harry and megan
as they continue to build their lives
overseas
and to my darling mama
thank you
thank you
for your love
and devotion
to our family
and to the family of nations
piers morgan will be joining us in a
second so
until he does let's take it around the
table i have to tell you jessica i was i
was really impressed with that speech
with the tone with the gravitas that i
heard in his voice with the sadness i
thought he was phenomenal i thought he
was really good too and i i kept
thinking through the whole thing having
recently lost a parent that i was just a
complete mess the day after think about
if you wake up the day after you lose a
parent and you have to become king or
queen and you have to go and console
millions of people i mean the second
that the reports came out that you know
she was under medical supervision they
started coming down to buckingham palace
and i've been there for events like that
the brits they will stay and they
love their monarchs and they want to see
them and
his ability to go out and to connect
with people at such a tough moment i i
really thought it was so impressive well
and you know sean it really is a
testament to
his mother i mean you know he has been
in the shadow of his mother for many
years i mean it's unusual to become king
at 73. uh but we have pierce morgan uh
joining us pierce are you there thank
you so much for joining us piers and i
can thank you i along with everyone at
the table um offer our sympathies to you
i heard you throughout the day today
talking about your relationship with the
royal family and we thank you very much
for being here so we're going to go
around the table but i'd like to start
with something piers if i might and it
has to do with king charles statement
about referring to camilla as the queen
consort as the queen uh elizabeth
indicated and then talking about kate
and william as the prince and princess
of wales and then of course going to uh
uh harry and megan not referring to them
as the duke and duchess of sussex just
saying and harry and megan um you know
my love to you as you continue to build
your lives in another country can you
translate that
well yes i think i can it's very clear
to me that what the new king charles iii
was saying was that william is his uh
eldest son and heir
and he will have a lot of titles
including prince of wales and he is very
much the future along his side of this
new slim down monarchy and he has
another son called harry he didn't give
him his title and harry has this wife
called megan and all right he said he
used the word love but they're building
their life
outside in another country and i think
that beneath all this there was a pretty
clear message
from charles
that he's getting a bit fed up with this
rival royal family
based in california spray gunning the
royals and the monarchy whenever it
suits him for huge personal enrichment
from companies like netflix and spotify
and i think he's saying look the future
of this monarchy under me
for now is going to be william and his
family who have been impeccably behaved
while all this nonsense has been going
on and you know they say don't they that
events like this this very traumatic
event for this country i have to say a
lot of emotion in britain right now
about losing this remarkable woman after
70 years but they say they're for
families that these kind of seismic
events can either pull people together
or make things 10 times worse i'm seeing
no sign other than it's got a lot worse
harry went up to balmoral on his own i
was told that meghan markle was going to
go with him and that plan was stopped by
people up in scotland and i and harry
left at about eight o'clock in the
morning i didn't even stay for breakfast
with his family he's been at frogmore
cottage in windsor literally half a mile
from his brother and they were once so
close as we know he didn't even say
hello to him they didn't meet didn't say
hello there's the most gigantic rift now
at the very heart of our new monarch
charles is distraught he's incredibly
hurt by what's been happening with his
son and his daughter-in-law and so he's
putting all his chips on william and i
think that's the right thing to do if i
were him i'd go further i would strip
megan and harry of all their titles
period done take them away
and i guess next to dana do you have a
question i mean obviously and piers that
could happen i understand that he does
have plans and he's obviously had a lot
of time to think about things he would
want to do with the monarchy i i wanted
to ask you about the commonwealth
overall do you think
that it can hold together or will there
be moves
to leave the commonwealth if i were a
smaller country i would want to stay
within it but you think about the
challenges that prince william and kate
had on their recent trip over the summer
these questions about uh the colonizers
right and it was very rough and i wonder
if you think that there might be some
movement there
well look there were some pretty
disgusting things that have been said i
have to say across the pond by various
so-called academics and journalists uh
on this very theme blaming queen
elizabeth for effectively all the sins
of the british empire and all
colonization and so on completely
outrageous given she was the one that
led of course us out of all that um i
think it's a very good question i think
most of the
countries remain in the commonwealth
want to stay in but there have been murm
rings amongst some and i think it will
be down to prince charles or king
charles iii now and the prince of wales
his son william they're going to have to
try and navigate some pretty tricky
waters they can't just go back to the
old tried and tested turn up in your
white suit looking colonial in an open
top jeep and hope for the best that's
not going to fly anymore so they're
going to have to be i think uh smarter
about the way they go about it but again
i come back i'm afraid to meghan markle
and harry if they keep chucking mud at
the royal family if he keeps spray
gunning the monarchy is an institution
if they keep saying that they're a bunch
of callus races that is going to cause a
lot of damage as it has been in the
commonwealth there's this book coming
right prince harry's supposed tell-all
memoir in which i'm told he's planning
to take down camilla for example he's
now the queen consul where does this end
this is a family at war and i think the
future of the monarchy and the
commonwealth is very contingent on how
much damage these two continue to want
to do to it
okay sean yeah appears it's important at
a time like this you try to unify your
family you've indicated listen this this
family is getting torn apart but to
unify prince charles said listen i'm not
i'm not going to be involved in politics
i'm going to be apolitical but as we all
know prince er now king charles has been
a climate activist uh for much of his
life do you see him actually giving up
the climate activism for the apolitical
role especially with the damage that
climate policies have caused in europe
well i'm told that he's very keen now
that he's the monarch to not continue
behaving in the way he did as prince of
wales he felt that being the prince of
wales gave him license to express
opinions to right to government
ministers to uh make his feelings clear
about issues like climate change but
i've been told by people very close to
him that he's determined now he's
monarch to pivot into a completely
non-partisan
non-polarizing inclusive style that his
mother had but it's difficult isn't it
if you're so well known for having these
strong views about issues like climate
change and so on can we really expect
him in his weekly meeting with the prime
minister who is now liz trust as of this
week can we expect him to keep quiet is
he going to be applying some soft power
pressure in those weekly meetings i
think he's going to find it very hard
because this is a guy who has repeatedly
written to government ministers in his
famous spidery writing
haranguing them about things like
climate change so i think it's going to
be very interesting to watch because he
can't really afford i don't think to
continue behaving the way he has done
when it comes to hot button issues and
politics
the the beauty of the queen's reign we
never knew what she thought about
anything she didn't tell us she was just
there as this overseeing non-partisan
figurehead and she was incredibly
popular and respected the moment you
start dipping your fingers into politics
as a as a monarch i think you're heading
into big trouble all right pierce now we
have one more with greg godfell hi
pierce hope you're doing well out there
uh you know there are a lot of people
here in the united states that are like
me and find royalty an unfamiliar
phenomenon so i'm going to ask you a
dumb question which is how do you
explain the role of the monarchy now to
people who aren't familiar with it and
what since you've lived in america what
in america comes close to fulfilling
that role and could it be something like
the five
[Laughter]
well the nearest i was about to say greg
that i keep reading that you are now the
king of late night tv so in a way
the american monarchy now rests on your
shoulders you are the king thank you and
we all are all lucky and feel fortunate
to be your loyal subjects
um no look i think the point what is the
point i was once asked by an american
journalist what is the point of a
monarchy and i said look the whole point
is there's not really a point they're
not elected officials what did the queen
do that made her so beloved and so
popular and why do we feel so
grief-stricken she's gone and i would
explain it to americans like this you
have presidents who come and go some are
good some are bad none of them last more
than eight years and then you move on
and you invest all your emotion and time
into a new family a new president we've
invested all our time and emotion for my
entire lifetime in one woman and her
family and she's barely put a foot wrong
in 70 years i can't think of a president
or prime minister who's gone seven
minutes without putting a football so
this woman was exceptional and what she
stood for are the kind of old-fashioned
values which i think you are missing in
society today she never played the
victim she never felt sorry for herself
it was never about her she wasn't
arrogant she was humble she believed in
stoicism and resilience mental strength
duty service to her country and i think
it was that which made britain great and
which we've sadly lost in recent times
that's what she stood for and i think if
you had a a figure like that i mean i
looked personally i think it was a great
shame you got rid of the monarchy from
america because
however you made that decision you've
you've you've tried to move on you now
have king drake it's not quite the same
ring doesn't sound quite as posh um but
i think she brought stability and she
was there as a kind of comfort blanket
in difficult times and someone to share
celebration in good times and i don't
think we realized quite how big a deal
she was to all of us individually until
we lost her and i gotta say it feels
like we've lost the kind of nation's
grandmother and uh imagine the most
beloved president you've ever had
who'd been there for 70 years and never
put a foot wrong and then they die
that's what it feels like for us so
what's the point of a monarchy the queen
was the point because she's the most
beloved public figure in the world and
god bless her all right pierce maybe you
can convey to your countrymen how many
americans feel the impact of the queen's
death as well i mean she was not a queen
in this country but so many of us
respected and idolized her for all of
the reasons that you just mentioned
piers thanks so much for being with us
and of course you can catch piers morgan
uncensored on fox nation hi winner
i want you to do me a favor i want you
to click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now